in the last video we showed that the
ratios of the sides of a 30-60-90
triangle are if we assume the longest
side is x if the hypotenuse is x then
the shortest side is x over 2 and the
the side in between the side that's
opposite the 60-degree side is square
root of 3x over 2 or another way to
think about it is if the shortest side
is 1
and i'll do the shorter side then the
medium side then the longest side so if
the side opposite the 30 degree side is
1 then the side opposite the 60 degree
side is square to 3 times that so it's
going to be square root of 3 and then
the hypotenuse is going to be twice that
in the last video we started with x and
we said that the 30 degree side is x
over 2 but if the 30 degree side is 1
then this is going to be twice that so
it's going to be 2. this right here is
the side opposite the 30 degree side
opposite the 60 degree side and then the
hypotenuse opposite the 90 degree side
and so in general if you see any
triangle that has those ratios you say
hey that's a 30 60 90 triangle or if you
see a triangle that you know is 360 or a
30-60-90 triangle you could say hey i
know how to figure out i know how to
figure out one of the sides based on
this ratio right over here just an
example if you see a triangle that looks
like this
where the sides are 2
2 square roots of 3 and 4. once again
the ratio of 2 to 2 square roots of 3 is
1 to square root of 3. the ratio of 2 to
4 is the same thing as 1 to 2. this
right here must be a 30-60-90 triangle
what i want to introduce you to in this
video is another important type of
triangle that shows up a lot in geometry
and a lot in trigonometry and this is a
45 45 90 triangle or another way to
think about it is if i have a right
triangle that is also isosceles
so a right triangle that is also
isosceles you obviously can't have a
right triangle that is equilateral
because an equilateral triangle has all
all of their angles have to be 60
degrees but you can have a right angle
you can have a right triangle that is
isosceles and isosceles let me write
this this is a right
right isosceles
isosceles
triangle
and if it's isosceles that means two of
the sides are equal so these are the two
sides that are equal
and then if the two sides are equal we
have proved to ourselves that the base
angles are equal and if we call the
measure of these base angles x then we
know that x plus x plus 90 have to be
equal to 180
x plus x plus 90 need to be equal to 180
or if we subtract 90 from both sides you
get x plus x is equal to 90 or 2x is
equal to 90 or if you divide both sides
by 2 you get x is equal to x is equal to
45 degrees so a right isosceles triangle
can also be called and this is the more
typical name for it it can also be
called a
90 triangle
45 45 90 triangle and what i want to do
in this video is come up with the ratios
for the sides of a 45-45-90 triangle
just like we did for a 30-60-90 triangle
this was actually more straightforward
because in a 45-45-90 triangle if we
call each of if we call one of the legs
x the other leg is also going to be x
and then we can use the pythagorean
theorem to figure out the length of the
hypotenuse so the length of the
hypotenuse let's call that c
c so we get
x squared
x squared plus x squared that's the
square of both of the length of both of
the legs
so when we sum those up that's going to
have to be equal to c squared this is
just straight out of the pythagorean
theorem so we get 2 x squared is equal
to c squared
c squared we can take the principal root
of both sides of that
i want to just change it to yellow and
it keeps not letting me okay to c
squared let's take the principal root of
both sides of that
principle root of both sides the
left-hand side you get principal root of
2 is just square root of 2 and then the
principal root of x squared is just
going to be x so you're going to have x
times the square root of 2 is equal to
is equal to c
so if you have a right isosceles
triangle whatever the two legs are
they're going to have the same length
that's why it's isosceles the hypotenuse
is going to be square root of 2 times
that so c is equal to
x times the square root of 2. so for
example if you have a triangle that
looks like this
let me draw it slightly different way
it's good to have to orient ourselves in
different ways every time so if we see a
triangle that's 90 degrees
45 and 45 like this and you really just
have to know two of these angles to know
that the other one what the other one is
going to be and if i tell you that this
side right over here is 3
i actually don't even have to tell you
that this other side is going to be 3.
this is an isosceles triangle so the two
legs are going to be the same and you
won't even have to apply the pythagorean
theorem if you know this and this is a
good one to know that the hypotenuse
here the side opposite the 90 degree
side is just going to be square to 2
times the length of either of the legs
so it's going to be 3
times the square root of 2. so the ratio
of the sides in a hypotenuse in a in a
45-45-90 triangle or a right isosceles
triangle the ratio of the sides are one
of the legs can be one then the other
leg's going to have the same measure the
same length and then the hypotenuse is
going to be square to two times either
of those
one to one two square root of two so
this is 45 45 90. let me write this is
45 45
90. that's the ratios and just as a
review if you have a 30
60 90 the ratios were 1 to square to 3
to 2 and now we'll apply this in a bunch
of problems